would you guys give up monogamy for a
guy that if you were really into a guy
it's like long term where you know he
could step out from time to time
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately yeah yeah it's been a
like you're the main chick but just you
know every now and again he steps out
possibly I don't know no why why you're
already the side chick that's what I
think in the guy you're sleeping with
like you're ready he's not monogamous so
I'm either side chick or am I the main
I'm just every now and then he can go
and yeah screw us out chick maybe not
not even a concubine
no way so how come she was the side
chick before
why was that aside yeah yeah if you're
happy to be the side chick because I
wasn't getting hurt okay but it's so
interesting to me because I'm just like
if I was gonna be a side chick I would
try to be the main chick
like how how would have been the main
chick I just chose not because the girl
told me of why it doesn't make no sense
if I'm okay
no I can't wait I'm not condoning this
okay so don't don't take this as me
condoning it or saying to do it so chat
okay but if you're gonna do it do it
right I swear to because we don't want
him like we don't want all of him we
just want certain parts so that's why we
don't want to upgrade for you that's not
what she said that's not what she said
yeah but she said she doesn't like she
didn't like his lives no no no no no I'm
not that guy in the beginning of the I
listen in the beginning of the show she
said that you you hope that you're gonna
like it'll be something someday or
whatever so I'm like if you're already
emotionally invested you already like
him why don't you just compete and try
to win ask her what does she have that I
don't I'm not I'm not saying I'm not
saying the odds are in your favor ask
the man you know that you come inside
you're gonna I'm just saying if you're
already in that position I would try to
win
and I don't understand like how you can
be like I'm not the one I'm not the one
getting hurt when it's like you're the
side chick and you're emotionally
invested go ahead I think the reason is
insecurity and paranoia of oh he cheated
on his girl with me so then if I get
with him he's gonna cheat on me if I
never go yeah but you're already staring
at all you're already sharing everyone's
trying to paint us on the men the road
the real person that's a side chick
you're not as emotionally involved like
if you're his actual girlfriend you're
in love or or whatever you're saying you
are so as a side chick you're not you're
not doing that so but you said in the
beginning that you're hoping that you'd
be promoted to Maine I mean you didn't
use those I'm that's how I would
describe it you said it in different
words but I remember you saying that in
the beginning I think not always though
like as as a whole lots of girls get
emotionally attached and then that's
when it obviously becomes a problem you
start thinking you know maybe I could
and that's probably when you start
trying to get him or trying to get him
to make you but in that situation in my
situation I had he wanted me but I
didn't want him so I didn't work so he
wanted he wanted to leave the main chick
for you um and you don't want him no do
you know what you said you were hoping
I'm not fused not always I I think that
like as a as a whole like if you are a
side chick you are hoping for that in
the end but like I didn't I didn't want
that I personally think that side chicks
don't want to become the main chick and
the reason is that no one's really
saying is because they have other men
that they are side chicks too it's true
this is the part that no one's talking
about I don't know a lot about I'm new
to the this is
I'm learning new stuff I don't want to
get promoted I don't want to get
promoted other options
that I'm working on okay so it's like I
can't work 40 hours a week
I can't I can't work 40 hours a week
because I got all I want to take out
multiple part-time jobs
and if I have a full-time job then I
have to get rid of my part-time jobs
which work out more valuable than a
one-time job I'm making 50k with all of
these so modern women want to be side
chicks absolutely they don't want to be
the man I thought I was feeling you
know
the feeling you wouldn't
plenty of you because the question we
didn't ask you is when you was a side
chick for that dude and you wanted to be
to be the main was you dealing with
somebody else too no you didn't have six
years for six years
there wasn't like someone who was like a
regular like you might end up meeting
someone else on like a night out and
then you get talking for a couple weeks
and then it sort of goes nowhere but
that that person within that six years
is still the same convenience still the
same person you go back but what about
you see when you said you was a side
chick when you was a sidekick to the guy
who was obviously with somebody else did
you have other partners was you with
other people
no not for the majority of the time no
way so when you was a psychic to that
guy you was loyal to your guy
he was loyal to the guy he was a side
chick off basically is that what you're
saying yeah pretty much because I'm
going to him for a reason what if if I
need if he's not fulfilling it what is
the point in guiding to him
that's what I don't know like three
sidemens
but you said you went on a date and I
slept with someone else after
yeah but it's not like a regular thing I
wouldn't be sleeping with like three
guys at the same time that's horrific
it's multiple attention though yeah
we're playing with we go into the
extreme to let you know we're playing
because if if the main guy that you said
that was your guy who used a side chick
for saw the messages that these do that
you ain't serious with right there we go
that's the smile I needed to see
he wouldn't be happy with those he'd be
like who's this
who's that what does he mean by that
what does he mean by this yeah but I
didn't have I wasn't that juggling
multiple guys at the same time but no
attention is a currency for women that
men do not have the the benefit of using
men can't use attention as currency
women can use that as currency in order
for us to do that we have to be in some
kind of Scandal but you can use
attention as currency so as much as you
say you're not cheating you're actually
getting attention from these random
dudes is a setup it's like someone
filling out an insurance claim or
filling out a form that's what they're
really doing that's what men are
actually doing when they're when they're
trying to interact with you they're
filling out a form trying to text those
boxes and if you take the right boxes in
the right order the Box opens the big
box opens that's how you get to the big
boxes
it's real [ __ ] that's how you get to the
big boxes by ticking the little box and
Men know that from since we're five
bring her a flower bring her a rose say
something nice open the door for
chivalry we've been taught that for
instance we was a kid so that means you
have been taught something
which is it has to be in response to
that so you know what we want
okay so you
monogamy you wouldn't give up monogamy
no you maybe yeah I'll consider it okay
I'll try it you try it are you jealous
have you guys ever been in a
non-monogamous well I guess she didn't
know it
have you ever been in an openly
non-monogamous relationship guys like
openly yeah like she knows you have a
side check yeah oh yeah was she crazy or
did she just look the other way
no she wasn't as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible